la Banque du Canada a une rôle
indépendante on appuie l'indépendance de
cette rôle c'est important mais je vais
aussi noter que le goulement du Canada
comment libéral a le pouvoir de mettre
en œuvre de proposer un mandat
[Musique]
d'alimenter les risques d'une récession
imminente en y allant de mesures trop
agressives des commentaires qui le
formulaient dans une lettre en voyage
Justin Trudeau où il critique les
hausses à répétition du taux directeur
notre critique de la Banque centrale qui
joint sa voix à la mêlée qu'est-ce que
ça peut avoir comme impact voyons
pouvoir se compense mes collaborateurs
avec castonguer est animateur de midi
info et si première chroniqueur au
Toronto Star et au magazine de
l'actualité et Michel est absent cette
semaine c'est le chef de bureau de
Radio-Canada Ottawa Madeleine blémorin
qui se joint à nous bonjour à vous trois
bonjour bonjour c'est une autre voie
Madeleine qui se joint dans le concert
la critique à l'endroit de la Banque du
Canada qu'est-ce que ça change comme
dynamique ou est-ce que ça change
quelque chose à la dynamique je suis pas
certaine que ça change véritablement
grand chose à la dynamique la ministre
des Finances va faire face à des temps
qui sont difficiles mais là elle est
prise à défendre la Banque du Canada
alors que le Parti conservateur
critiquer la Banque du Canada maintenant
le NPD critique la Banque du Canada
donc elle doit défendre la Banque du
Canada parce que sans quoi la banque va
être affaiblie et va devoir pédaler
encore plus fort pour finalement se
faire entendre pour avoir un impact sur
l'économie donc Christophe wilan fait
face à des temps difficiles à leur
annoncer ses couleurs au cours de
discours au cours des dernières semaines
on a l'impression que on n'aura pas de
grandes grandes mesures là dans la mise
à jour économique on attend jeudi
prochain parce que elle veut démontrer
que le gouvernement fédéral est pas
étrangers la posture des Canadiens en
général on n'est pas là pour dépenser de
façon excessive et finalement contrer
les efforts de la Banque du Canada
mise à jour économique qui va être
déposée jeudi manque d'amis quand même
un peu Chantal monsieur maclain ça ça va
pas s'attache très facile
non un mot sur Jack mything c'est tout à
fait légitime pour un parti d'opposition
même pour le gouvernement de vouloir
repenser au mandats de la Banque du
Canada d'autres partenaires du Canada
défini ouais on redéfinit
la mission de de leur banque centrale
mais ça arrive tard c'est le genre de
discussion qui aurait été plus
susceptible de se faire à tête à moitié
reposée au moins le printemps dernier
tandis que là ça a l'air plus
opportuniste que d'autres choses ça
coïncide néanmoins avec un consensus
parmi les économistes qui est beaucoup
plus fragile sur les choix de la Banque
du Canada et ça ça place les libéraux
dans une drôle de position effectivement
ils sont tenus de défendre
l'indépendance de la banque je vous
dirais que ça place la banque aussi dans
une drôle de position tout le monde dans
les milieux bancaires et autres
s’attendaient cette semaine à une
alimentation trois quarts de points
ça a été un demi point et là évidemment
à cause de ces attaques qui viennent de
la droite comme de la gauche
la question ou l'impression ça a été
finalement la banque avait reculé devant
le ventre front qui devenait de plus en
plus fort c'est ça la banque a-t-elle
réagi aux critiques devant elle ça
soulève la question c'est ça c'est pas
simple pour la banque c'est pas simple
pour le gouvernement aussi qui tente de
maintenir l'indépendance tout en
essayant de se défendre contre les
attaques qui sont livrés contre Monsieur
maclem
je pense la Banque du Canada est tout à
fait consciente des critiques qu'elle
subit depuis maintenant plusieurs mois
d'avoir été peut-être trop lente à
remonter les taux maintenant on l'accuse
d'être trop agressive
dans dans son rythme et je pense surtout
moi que la Banque du Canada a les yeux
sur le taux d'endettement des Canadiens
et que
plus réagit à ça qu'à Jack mythique
cette semaine en augmentant moins que
prévu le taux directeur
certains là dans les derniers jours vous
savez dans les années 80 on avait des
taux directeurs pas mal plus élevés que
ça on s'énerve avec trois points 25
3.75% oui mais l'endettement des
Canadiens est pas le même le prix des
maisons des hypothèques non plus il y a
une limite à ce que la Banque du Canada
peut augmenter et je pense qu'elle vient
de s'en rendre compte il y a des gens
qui vont avoir de la difficulté vraiment
la rencontrer leurs obligations alors il
y a ça dont la Banque du Canada doit
tenir compte et le message que l'a
envoyé cette semaine non seulement en
réduisant en augmentant moins rapidement
mais vous savez le rebond devrait venir
ça devrait pas être trop long la
récession devrait être courte en voulant
dire vous savez il y a des jours heureux
qui s'enviennent tout ça ça répond aux
critique qui disent vous allez nous
plonger leur artificiellement dans une
récession la bande du Canada répond mais
c'est pour votre bien là le côté plus
difficile pour le gouvernement de Justin
Trudeau c'est comment défendre ça c'est
indépendance là de la banque alors que
effectivement ça va brasser dans les
prochains mois il va y avoir là une
danse un tango entre le gouvernement et
l'indépendance de la banque qui sera pas
simple pour le gouvernement Trudeau
c'est pour votre
et jusqu'où est-ce que le gouvernement
veut défendre la Banque du Canada en
toute confiance en sachant qu'il y a un
an la Banque du Canada disait
l'inflation faites vos enfants ça va
être circonstanciel tout va bien c'est
la même banque alors évidemment pour le
gouvernement de se lier à la Banque du
Canada comme un oracle c'est un petit
peu risqué politiquement parce que la
crédibilité de la banque on s'entend est
assez amoché parce que
les banques centrales se sont plantés
dans leur pronostics sur l'inflation qui
qui guettait la pré pandémie et qui
n'est pas du tout
aussi passagère que ce qu'ils avaient
prédit même en ajoutant la guerre en
Ukraine le faité que tout était tout
étant mis là-dedans
c'est normal que les gens regardent ça
ils se disent voyons donc c'est la même
banque qui a dit au gouvernement il y a
un an tout va bien aller tu travailles
une introspection à faire peut-être
après la crise on verra je vais faire on
va faire un show du côté de Québec un
autre crise celle là dans les hôpitaux
dans les urgences des hôpitaux le
ministre de la Santé Christian Dubé qui
a commenté cette semaine sur sa piste de
solutions à l'écoute puis je vous
reviens tout de suite après
on va faire une cellule de crise avec
trois quatre PDG à Montréal puis on va
s'assurer que la collaboration qu'on
veut avoir comment puis-je vous dirais
pas les mesures additionnelles qu'on va
faire parce que ça va être la cellule de
crise une suggérer mais cette salue
cette cellule de crise locale
va venir nous faire des recommandations
très spécifiques
avec cellule de crise la dernière fois
qu'on a parlé d'une cellule de crise
c'est en début de covid est-ce que c'est
la piste à préconisé pour régler le
problème que l'on connaît dans les
urgences des hôpitaux du Québec est-ce
que ça va faire une différence
moi c'est une des rares fois où j'ai eu
l'impression que Christian Dubé
improvisait quelque chose sous la
pression de l'opinion publique vous
savez c'est un gestionnaire en assez
grand contrôle Christian Dubé quand il
arrivait pendant les points de presse la
pandémie tout était déjà attaché voici
ce qu'on va faire clique santé était
déjà à jour toute fonctionné au moment
où on l'annonçait on avait prévu tout on
avait été testé
tout fonctionnel et là on annonce une
cellule de crise pour le lendemain on
sait pas qui siège au cette cellule de
crise là à quelle heure ils vont se
rencontrer comment ça va fonctionner et
même le lendemain rendu à l'heure du
midi personne ne le savait on parla des
gens dans le milieu de la santé allez
voir sur le comité c'est qui les experts
dont on parle personne le savait dans
les urgencesologues dans ceux qui sont
concernés et faire une cellule de crise
avec 3-4 PDG de 6 dessus j'imagine qu'il
leur parle assez souvent alors si on
voulait faire quelque chose d'un peu
plus différent ou l'âge que d'habitude
j'ai eu l'impression qu'on l'a annoncé
avant même la structure avant même pas
vraiment un plan de travail une des
renforts où je trouve que Christian Dubé
là peut-être été réactif sans vraiment
avoir réfléchi à ce qu'elle est advenir
de ce comité-là de cette cellule de
crise là donc avant de vous dire est-ce
que c'est la bonne solution je sais même
pas certain de qui siège sur ce
comité-là et de ce qu'ils vont faire
alors je vais me garder une petite gêne
en ayant en ayant la réponse à cette ok
on va reparler on veut ça sur le sur le
rôle en arrière on en reparlera dans
quelques semaines chantant puis ensuite
Madeleine
de toute façon on saurait on le saurait
pourquoi parce que c'est un problème qui
est généralisé dans le moment au Canada
c'est un problème il y a une crise en
Ontario et une crise en Colombie
Britannique donc
c'est pas un phénomène qui est unique au
Québec et aucun de ces gouvernements
donc je viens de parler tout à coup
trouvé une formule magique pour résoudre
le problème cela dit il y a un dicton en
anglais là que toute bonne crise est
également une opportunité et on l'a vu
cette semaine les provinces sont sautées
sur cette crise pour faire une campagne
publicitaire pour dire on a besoin de
plus d'argent du fédéral en passant l'un
est pas relié à l'autre et même si
Monsieur Trudeau signait un chèque
demain matin ça pègre pas le problème à
moins de transformer le chèque en
infirmière et en docteur mais néanmoins
ça prépare une ronde politique
fédérale provincial sur la santé qui
s'annonce assez corset médecine est-ce
que Madeleine j'allais vous amener
là-dessus que ça change la donne parce
que on les attend assez négociations
entre les provinces et le fédéral là les
ministres la santé vont rencontrer
Monsieur Duclos dans deux semaines je
fais des poussières est-ce que ça change
de dynamique à la table de négociation
mais c'est sûr que ça donne des
arguments aux provinces mais vous voyez
on a vu Christian Dubé annoncé cette
cellule de crise là quand on a une crise
comme ça dans les urgences on se tourne
vers la province on se tourne vers le
ministre de la santé de la province on
se tourne vers le premier ministre de la
province on n'est pas en train d'appeler
ou de demander à Jean-Yves Duclos
pourquoi ça tourne carré dans les
hôpitaux au Québec par exemple donc
c'est vraiment en ce moment les
provinces qui ressentent cette pression
là mais ça leur donne des arguments
supplémentaires pour aller voir le
fédéral et dire vous voyez raison de
plus pour avoir une augmentation des
transferts là où on s'entend pas en fait
on s'entend pas sur beaucoup de choses
là j'ai l'impression que c'est
négociation là vont être très
compliquées ça fait des mois que les
provinces répètent qu'elle veut faire
passer la peur des paiements fédéraux le
22 pour cent à 35 % c'est une hausse
substantielle et quand on regarde dans
le dernier budget du gouvernement
fédéral le gouvernement fédéral prétend
déjà payer 33% des frais de santé des
soins de santé en que ce soit en
transfert ou en transfert de points
d'impôts donc voyez-vous on s'entend
même pas sur le chiffre de départ j'ai
l'impression que ça va être quand même
assez compliqué comme négociation
un mot sur un autre un autre sujet qui a
retenu l'attention à Québec je commence
avec vous Chantal madame Anglade cette
semaine qui s'est permis d'expulser
l'une de ses députés quelques semaines
après l'élection Marie-Claude Nicole
Nicole qui qui siègera comme indépendant
parce qu'elle n'a pas voulu accepter les
responsabilités que Madame anglaise
voulait lui confier dans son cabinet
fantôme est-ce que c'est ça passe la
barre des bonnes raisons ça
ça ajoute une raison
inédite
pour qui cause un congédiment de cocus
parce que je me souviens pas d'avoir vu
un chef d'opposition de gouvernement
mettre quelqu'un à la porte d'un caucus
parce qu'il voulait pas un dossier ou
un rôle à l'intérieur du caucus
d'ailleurs à chaque fois qu'il y a des
cabinets fantômes dans l'opposition
Ottawa on se fait dire qu'il y a des
gens qui ont pas de poste parce qu'on
demandait à pas en avoir
ou parce qu'ils ont pas eu chaussures à
leurs pieds puis ils sont pas en train
de siéger comme indépendant à l'arrière
de la Chambre des communes ça a eu pour
effet deux choses selon moi ça a
fragilisé encore davantage le leadership
de Madame Anglade elle a montré la porte
à une députée qui vient de se faire
élire sous sa bannière alors qu'elle en
avait pas à perdre et ça fait qu'on
parle de ça et pas de son cabinet
fantôme Madeleine votre lecture de ça
puis ensuite j'ai l'impression que
Madame Anglade essayait peut-être de
faire un coup de force en lui montrant
la porte mais en même temps ça démontre
plutôt une situation de faiblesse parce
que effectivement elle perd une membre
de son caucus alors qu'elle en a pas
beaucoup à perdre en ce moment il y a
pas assez de monde dans son focus pour
avoir un poste équivalent pour chaque
ministre donc déjà les les membres du
cabinet fantôme devaient cumuler des
fonctions pour essayer d'égaler ce qui
se passe dans le cabinet ministériel là
elle perd une joueuse une joueuse
d'expérience c'est pas une bonne journée
pour eux ça envoie un bien drôle de
message au troupes Alec alors que Madame
anglaise sont les deux Shop et payez pas
il est pas assis il est pas
confortablement assis dans sa chaise il
y a des grenouillage en arrière des gens
qui sont pas convaincus que devrait
rester là ça fait rien pour aider sa
cause
secret de polichinelle que Madame Nicoz
et dominicarglad ne s'entendait pas très
bien ils avaient pas une bonne relation
personnelle madame Nicos n'avait pas
appuyé Dominique Anglade lors de la
course à la direction
mais c'est pas une raison
sous-jacente pour mettre un député
dehors je disais oui elle voulait être
vice-président de l'Assemblée nationale
Dominique de choisir quelqu'un d'autre
prend du benjamin pour la pour ce poste
là d'accord allez voulait pas donc être
critique au transport on aurait pu la
laisser sur les banquettes arrières on
aurait pu expliquer qu'elle ne voulait
pas drôle et là subira les critiques de
ses collègues et de la population parce
qu'elle ne veut pas être porte-parole
d'un dossier mais une expulsion de cocus
un mois après avoir été élu sous la
bannière libérale on s'entend que des
milliers de citoyens qui ont voté pour
Madame Nicole parce qu'elle était
libérale et donc un moment donné on l'a
mal à l'extérieur du caucus on la force
à siéger comme indépendante pour une
raison assez obscure de elle a pas
accepté le poste de critique je lui
proposait on met la barre bien base de
la prochaine fois ça va être quoi ça va
être vous avez pas la bonne couleur de
base
vous avez attaché vos lancers de la
mauvaise manière à un moment donné c'est
que les gens se disent attendez on peut
tout faire de la politique pour les
bonnes raisons l'animosité entre les
deux femmes et pas une raison pour
expulser quelqu'un d'un caucus moi je
trouve que c'est nettement exagéré
rapidement
non et cette barbe ça elle va revenir en
thé non pas la députée du siège comme
indépendant mais la chef du parti parce
qu'il va y en avoir d'autres événements
beaucoup plus difficile à gérer et si
elle continue à montrer la porte aux
gens au moindre à la moindre incartable
Québec solidaire va devenir l'opposition
sur ces sur cette sage conclusion on
sait ce là-dessus on reprend ça la
semaine prochaine Alex Chantal Madeleine
merci à vous trois au revoir au revoir